If you understand store now the cry
later which means that um nation states
are stealing our information. They are
storing it. They can't read it now but
they are holding it until they have a
quantum computer ready. And they will
read it in three, four, five, six years
when they have the quantum computer.
Which means our information today is in
danger today. Not tomorrow when the
quantum computer is ready but today. So
the governments and major CISOs and
companies that understand this they say
I need a plan to protect myself against
that but then they use the tool and they
say hold on your tool is helping me not
only with that but it's also helping me
understand my classical encryption today
because infrastructure is huge and there
are many instances of your
infrastructure that are across
everywhere and globally if you done a
lot of M&As you are acquiring
infrastructure and they have in
cryptography that in many places that
you don't know you have it or you don't
have cryptography. One in five breaches
come because of a credential that was
lost or not updated at the right time.
So that tool is helping you uh monitor
and modernize today and preventing you
from the future.
[music]
All right, Fernando, thank you so much
for joining me here on 20-minute
leaders. How you doing?
>> I'm doing great. Thank you, Michael, for
inviting me.
>> No, thank you for for taking the time to
do this. You guys are on a big mission
and you're up to big things and so
taking time out of the day today h to
make this happen is fully appreciated.
Uh, Fernando, uh, you're holding really
interesting work today with Sandbox AQ,
a company that I've been following
closely for for quite some time. In
fact, my my dad is an adviser within the
company since its founding. And and Jack
Hittery is is a phenomenal being. And if
the two of you are working together,
then that means that you are a
phenomenal being. And so really excited
to have you on here. Thank you again for
joining me. Tell me a little bit about
yourself and you know h how did you even
you know find your career trajectory
ending up today with Sandbox AQ.
>> Sure. Well, first your dad Yosi Matias
is more than adviser. I feel like he's
an inspiration. If we can do half of
what he's done at Google in the last
decades uh with sandbox that will be a
huge success.
>> And wow. My my journey is um I I started
industrial engineering and I studied in
France. I ended up working in the energy
industry which today is becoming very
relevant again uh with everything that
is happening with the data centers and
high performance computing. Uh and then
I ended up somehow uh Google Latin
America where Google was expanding in
Latin America helping Google products
expand in some of those world were
Google maps crisis response Google news
YouTube advertisement that was a time
when digital advertising wasn't that
known yet. So we had to teach everyone
about why why they had to be in the
digital world when today it's so obvious
back back in the day it was like this is
why you have to be on it and mobile
phones were not that on yet but I wanted
to go back to my roots of engineering
and I started helping Google X projects
that were projects that were not aligned
with the main business of Google like
the self-driving cars project LON that
was connectivity with balloons
I joined Google X for an energy project
and I spent six years at Google X
working in many different projects from
robotics, machine learning or AI when it
was called machine learning and many
different projects in robotics, uh
logistics, uh climate change,
agriculture, all projects at big
thinking. That was the if I had to say
the thing that I learned the most at
Google X, it was think big. You have to
have a big impact. Let's go. And you
know, Ferando, just to pause you for a
second, I actually just saw I just saw I
looked it up and I interviewed Mike
Cassidy for 20 minute leaders 5 years
ago. Four years ago in 11 months. So
December of 2021
2021 or 2020. Five years ago. Wow.
>> Yes. I I never worked directly with him,
but um I crossed paths with him. He was
leaving when I was arriving. He was one
of the ones at the start and launched
Project Lon as well. Yeah, I think.
>> Exactly. Yeah. So, so, so think big. So,
you you learn to think big and you were
working on these huge projects that are,
you know, all of them are are huge. Each
one that you mentioned. Yes. And in that
cross path, I mean, Google, it doesn't
sound that obvious, but thinking big is
one of the things that I see the most at
Silicon Valley uh and also in the
American uh culture. is like I'm going
to build something that is really going
to change the world which is something
that other nations other cultures don't
really have embedded into them and also
that you can bring your idea and nothing
is considered stupid. So you can put any
idea on the table and you know you're
not going to be considered as a fool
because you're thinking too big about
it. Uh the best example is let's go to
the moon uh Kennedy uh in the 50s and
60s. So that that's a that's a moonshot.
That's the main mantra of Google X.
Let's think 10x. And Sergey Alari, you
probably know this. They always push you
to the limits when you say, "I'm going
to do 20 of these." They're going to
come back and say, "Why not 200 10x?"
>> Absolutely. And And so how did that
shape, you know, the way that Sandbox AQ
got, you know, got started here? And and
tell me a little bit about the story of
of Sandbox.
The story comes from Sergey hiring Jack
Hidari, our CEO, as an entrepreneur
residence. And he started bringing more
science into software engineering, more
physics, uh more professors from
Stanford, from Berkeley coming and
teaching methods and techniques that
were using academia and then started
inviting all software engineers to
listen to those techniques and try to
use them uh out there. neural networks,
CNN's and uh tensor networks. All these
techniques that today are like some of
the principles of AI back then this was
2015 maybe 2017 uh attention is all you
need is a paper of transformers that was
published in 2017. So that's when that's
how sandboxes started more as an
educational platform uh to bring science
into all Google products and then we
started converging AI with quantum
physics. When you think about physics,
you think about quantum physics and you
think about all the techniques that have
been developed in academia to try to
understand that field. Now, can we take
them from academia and use them to solve
real problems and application problems
today? And we started converging those
two words. That's where the A and the Q
from sandbox AQ come from. It's
converging AI and quantum. Today sounds
more obvious. You're going to you listen
more and more quantum AI or AI and
quantum. Even Jensen from Nvidia uh has
gone from in January at CES saying that
quantum computers were 15 20 years away
to radically change invest in three four
of the top companies in quantum and AI
including sandbox AQ and launching last
week they launched the first hardware
product for performing high performance
computing with quantum computers and
classical comput. So in nine months,
Nvidia has a step up and said these two
technologies are going together. That's
how we started six, seven years ago. We
work very close with the quantum
computing team at Google in Santa
Barbara and we they were doing an
excellent job and we say we're not going
to be working on quantum computers. But
quantum technologies are much more than
just quantum computers. We're talking
about quantum sensors, we're talking
about uh simulation, and we're talking
about cyber security and communications.
And that's all all the areas that we
discovered at Sandbox AQ and it was so
big so relevant that we said we need
independence and autonomy to go faster
and capture capture this web.
>> Yeah. And what what are the different
use cases uh where the convergence of AI
and quantum computing really you know
are you know the I know that they're
going to change almost everything in the
way that we think through running you
know computationally difficult problems
but if we actually look at the at these
next couple of years and the world in
which sandbox is playing at today how do
you see the big use cases shaping up to
be right Now
>> that's a a good question. So let me show
the first one which includes the word
quantum but doesn't have that much of
quantum which is protection cyber
security and a threat. Quantum computers
mean a new way of computing, a new
different way uh not only faster but
different which means that exposes
encryption as we know it today. RSA and
in 1994 Peter Shaw published an
algorithm that said if one day we have a
quantum computer this algorithm we break
encryption as we know it today. Back in
the day we didn't have a road map for
quantum computers. Today we do and we
have many players and a lot of
investment on achieving uh that road map
to achieve the 1 million cubits that we
need. So now we have the threat and we
have the solution to perform that threat
but to protect yourself against that
threat. You don't need a quantum
computer. You just need to change the
algorithms that you're using to encrypt
your data. And that's what we call
postquantum encryption
uh PQC.
And we discovered by trying to apply
this that first we need to modernize
encryption. Modernizing encryption means
like what is being done manually today
looking for the encryption the
credentials the PKIs that you have
inside your entire infrastructure is
being done manually everywhere because
encryption has never been a priority in
most organizations.
>> So that's a lot of what we're doing with
the department of defense and with many
of the banks and many different players
across the the globe. It's modernizing
encryption and right now that we have
the inventory of all the encryption that
you have in your infrastructure which
ones are classical which ones you have
to update and create a crypto agility to
protect yourself against the future
threat of quantum computers.
>> Now you adding AI threats because all
organization are using AI many different
ways. We're exposing ourselves. we have
AI and a company with 30 40 50,000
employees all using AI tools having AI
agents coming through your organization
is a similar problem so you have to
create an inventory of what AI bots are
coming to your infrastructure and who
are they what's the identity of those AI
tools and are they allowed to access the
information we're trying to give them
access or not so that this new wave of
AI is creating new vulnerabilities and
we need to protect that as
It sounds like that even before you know
we we talk about where how how do
quantum computers and AI you know help
maybe catalyze or accelerate a bunch of
these healthcare use cases, financial
use cases, etc. You're even saying wait
hold on even by the mere fact that we
can now we can now design and lay out a
road map for for the for the capability
of how of achieving this million cubits.
Right now we actually need to revisit
the entire encryption infrastructure,
modernize it from the manual processes
of identifying the PKIs etc. and and to
upgrade to what you call crypto agility
so that as quantum computers become a
reality you're able to constantly evolve
and adapt the cryptographic mechanisms
and and and so it's really interesting
to hear in you know when you're talking
to governments like the department of
defense and banks etc you know how does
it actually look like I mean because
it's it's almost sounds like they have
to pop open the hood and start you know
looking through their entire
infrastructure
Well, they love it. They love the tool
because they say this is not only
helping me with a future threat, which
is not that distant. If you understand
store now, decrypt later, which means
that um nation states are stealing our
information. They are storing it. They
can't read it now, but they are holding
it until they have a quantum computer
ready. And they will read it in three,
four, five, six years when they have the
quantum computer. Which means our
information today is in danger today,
not tomorrow when the quantum computer
is ready, but today. So the governments
and major CISOs and companies that
understand this, they say, "I need a
plan to protect myself against that."
But then they use the tool and they say,
"Hold on, your tool is helping me not
only with that, but it's also helping me
understand my classical encryption
today." Because infrastructure is huge
and there are many instances of your
infrastructure that are across
everywhere and globally if you've done a
lot of M&A you're acquiring
infrastructure and have in cryptography
that in many places that you don't know
you have it or you don't have
cryptography one in five breaches come
because of a credential that was lost or
not updated on the right time. So that
tool is helping you uh monitor and
modernize today and preventing you from
the future.
Makes sense. What are you excited most
about in this in the world of the
postquantum computing?
>> That's a good question. The simulation
part is very interesting. So everybody's
expecting the quantum computers to come
and run those high performance computing
algorithms and problems that we can't
tackle today. Pharma it's a big part of
it. Energy that we talked about it in
the few at the beginning of this talk is
another one. Most of what we do in the
world is molecules. It's atoms talking
to each other interacting with each
other. So when we think about high
performance computing when we think
about the AI revolution that we're in
right now, most of what we're talking
about and what people are focused on are
Gen AI. Genai is great but it works with
words and words can only get you so far
and it's going to have a huge impact in
programming for coding and in content
creation so marketing customer support
etc. But it's not really impacting the
real economy, the physical world uh that
Jensen calls which is the what impacts
the GDP of the country. That's
manufacturing, that's production, that's
designing a car, that design a new
molecule, a new drug uh for a disease.
That's chemistry, that's biology, that's
mathematics, that's physics. That's what
we are using which is large quantitative
models which are models of AI trained on
equations that we know have been working
for 100 years not just on words but also
on numbers quantitative so that's what's
really going to have an impact and
that's the next big wave of AI that is
coming right now but because it will
impact energy companies uh financial
institutions when you talk about finance
banking that's numbers that's
mathematics that's physics when you talk
about a pharma company or a new chemical
company that it's runs most of the
combination of molecules that run our
world in agriculture in new materials
refineries. We created new open-source
data sets for catalyst for example for
energy companies catalysts are in the
core business and the core elements of
energy transition and hydrocarbon
cycles. So that's what really runs our
world and that's what's really coming
right now. That's the the AI apply to
the physical world, not just the digital
world.
And what role long-term does Sandbox
want to play? What role long-term does
Sandbox want to play in this world of
postquantum? Does it really want to be
this infrastructure layer of you know
the of of the encryption and the crypto
agility? Does it have you know different
visions? That's that's a good question.
I mean we we are a cyber security
platform and we started with the
postquantum approach we extended into
all encryption now we are extending
again to AI solutions it's it's all
about protecting our clients and so what
the seasons are needing in of credential
access cryptography protecting your data
your infrastructure and have a positive
impact at scale that's what we're trying
to help our partners with
>> and see it's it must be pretty exciting
you know being at the forefront of this
for for a few years now already uh even
well well before Genai even started
right
yes in fact uh we started using Tensson
networks and which is a technique that
comes from quantum physics with
transformers back in the day when we
were at Google and that's one of that
was one of the first proofs of concept
that we had when the team was very small
to say
these techniques that come from academia
and that have never been used in an
application can really impact uh
everything we're doing. Uh so
transformers come from a long time ago
like from 2017 that was a famous paper
that we talked about. Everybody has seen
it through open AI but but it's it has a
lot of implications.
>> Yeah. You know it's funny how you're
saying long time and I'm thinking yeah
well eight years seems like a very very
long time these days and uh Everything
that's happened in the last three five
years is it's crazy and more than is
happening right everything goes so fast
in the next two three years uh
everything is going to change a lot
>> yeah and and I think you know I'm I'm
looking at the industry even from a from
a VC perspective you're seeing new
venture capital firms forming just for
quantum you're seeing com you know
companies that are not only raising
their C series A but they're raising
series C series D in quantum um you're
seeing different layers of quantum from
the hardware and what Jensen is talking
about all the way to the you know how to
how do you write the new programming
languages for it and how do you write
the right the relevant software to
engage with it. Uh, so it really feels
like we're, you know, we're like this
there's like this whole world that's
about to to evolve that and it seems
also that that most of the world is not
really talking about it yet, right? It
seems like people are still very
occupied with Gen AI and and what we
have you don't hear about quantum still
that often at least not as often as I
think we should be compared to where we
are.
>> Is that right?
>> I hear it more and more often. I'll give
you two examples. Uh when we started
five six years ago, most cyber security
teams had never heard of postquantum
cryptography. Now every major company
and government has a plan for it. They
might not already have the solution or
acting on it, but they have a plan and
they are working on it. That's a big big
difference. The other one is
understanding that these two
technologies AI and quantum technologies
go together. It's not I need an AI team
and I need a quantum team. It's the new
talent that we are hiring are
computational chemists, computational
biologists, computational physicists.
These are the new generations of talent
that understand that the digital world
and the physical world work go together
and they're going to look at the problem
and then converge all the solutions, all
the tools they have and AI and quantum
technologies are tools they're going to
use to solve that problem. They're not
going to differentiate. Oh, I'm going to
just going to use AI or I'm just going
to use quantum. I'm going to use AI when
I need it and quantum when I need it.
I'm going to use them together. The
other example is you see all the big
companies even in Nvidia you mentioned
or Microsoft they calling the team even
Google the Google team is called quantum
plus AI. It used to be called quantum
now quantum AI. Microsoft is quantum and
AI. Nvidia is AI and quantum. you you
seen everybody's realizing that quantum
is not as far as we thought and that AI
and quantum go together that's very
important
what is one thing that you think all of
us should keep in mind as we enter this
postquantum world as either as
entrepreneurs
you know those working you know on the
frontier of new technologies whether
it's in healthcare or agriculture or
finance what is something that we should
be keeping in mind from today.
That's a good question.
I I can think of
learning and adapting. It's
nobody knew the best example is
transformers was created at Google. We
Google was the king of search and of uh
the technology.
Now GPT is there. all these LLMs and now
AI for the physical world it's having an
impact the most important part I think
is what kind of impact are you having
with the technology you're using at
Sunbox is all about positive impact at
scale so we bring the scale mentality
from Google X the positive part of it
because we want to make good in the
world but it's it's about like what are
you using are words enough to have an
impact words are really good But maybe
not enough. We need to bring chemistry.
We need to be physics. We need to bring
biology, which is what governs our
world. And that's what we're going to
impact. We're going to solve the energy
crisis that we are in. We have a huge
energy demand. We're going to solve the
climate change. We're going to solve a
new materials. We need new materials,
more resistant, lighter, more uh
sustainable. That's only going to come
if we use these technologies the right
way. And that's going to be very very
positive and very impactful for the next
generation.
>> Fernando, thank you so much for spending
this time with me. I'll let you go back
to doing amazing things. Uh and uh
really appreciate it. Been inspiring to
watch the journey of Sandbox from the
side and very interesting and eye
opening to hear your your optimism and
your perspective moving forward. And
obviously you're you're one of a few
that are getting a front row seat to
this transformation in the real
day-to-day. And you know I I coming in
from a cyber security background you
know I can definitely relate to how the
conversation is shifting and like you're
mentioning 5 years ago most cyber
security teams haven't heard of this
stuff and haven't thought about you know
quantum. Now, practically every large
organization has a plan for how to deal
with this postquantum world. And it's
not just putting another another cyber
security vendor. Okay, here's browser
security, here's next cloud security,
here's next identity. No, this is a
fundamental shaping [snorts]
of of how we defend and protect the
integrity of our information.
And how do we now make use of quantum
for in ways we haven't been able to yet?
So, Fernando, thank you so much for
joining me today.
Thank you, Michael.